so when you come to one of these things
you're not only just like doing the
press the obligation but you're seeing
old friends what I'm actually seeing
people that are rooting for me and I say
they're rooting for me because I've
known them a long time they've known me
for a very long time and they've seen me
hustle for a long time and so I feel
um you know I dress today very
specifically to be everybody everywhere
all at once I wanted to be inclusive
today and have sort of be surrounded by
the beautiful Good Will of people all
over the world who have been really
lovely and very supportive of my this
moment for me
I've seen the literal faces on the
it's good and I love that part of your
sag speech last week about how it you
know after you know
the shocks yes it doesn't make I watched
it somebody showed it to me none of it
makes sense I'm like talking about my
parents my parents were my grandparents
were from Hungary in Denmark my father
was born in New York City you know it's
like my shock speech yes what about it
yeah no I loved I love that you alluded
that this is you know the culmination of
years and years and years and years of
hard work and it's and it's paying off
wow like what's going through your mind
now we're a week out from the Oscars I'm
sure all of this feels very surreal
right
it feels surreal and perfect I'm I live
I live a mile from here I walk by here
all the time like I'm just in my body
and in my life in a beautiful way I'm in
my neighborhood right now I didn't have
to drive very far I'm wearing sensible
shoes and I'm wearing a suit of
everybody everywhere all at once to to
sort of surround me with the good Juju
and Vibes so I'm in Grace you've just
listed everything for like an LA person
like in their Venn diagram to have like
the best morning ever yes best morning
close to my house I didn't have to drive
far my shoes are good it's all good uh
if you win today who Are You Gonna Kiss
there's more like an impromptu
spontaneous who's ever no I actually
kissed Michelle until they showed me I
I'm telling you the word shock you
people you must think we all think we're
gonna win things
I'm not of that ilk I don't wake up
going like I'm gonna win I don't think
about it I try not to think about it for
one second because it's not about that
for me it's about the actual work I get
to do and the rest of this is just the
sort of Make-Believe part weirdly enough
weirdly enough since the make-believe
part is the work this part is make
believe to me so I'm in shock when that
happened and I don't really remember
what happened who told you and then what
did you say to Michelle after that
what did I say to Michelle well I didn't
I saw her
only right when the movie won and we all
just were celebrating I love her we love
each other
foreign